أنا عاطفي للغاية عندما يتعلق الأمر
بهاتفي ، لا أستطيع رؤية شخص ما يسقط هاتفي
، لا أستطيع رؤية شخص ما يخدشها ، هؤلاء هم
أطفالي ، هذا هو جاي أشكالي ولديه
مجموعة غريبة جدًا
لسنوات جايش كان ينمو بشكل هائل
مجموعة من الهواتف المحمولة المختلفة 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 - كم عدد الهواتف بالضبط
اليوم لقد عدت جميع الهواتف
وهؤلاء هم 20371 لذا فقد مرت 5 إلى 6
سنوات لقد بدأت في جمع هذا الهاتف
لقد جمعت الهواتف المحمولة من كل
مكان  العالم منكم تعرف أوروبا ، المملكة المتحدة ،
سويسرا ، دبي ، الكثير من البلدان ،
زوجتي غاضبة جدًا مني لأنني
استخدمت كل دواليب ملابسها ، كل
هاتفي في غرفة النوم ، معظمها
في السيارات في الخزائن في كل مكان
في المنزل ، مرحبًا
جايش هو  بدأ هوس هذه الهواتف
بأول هاتف له Nokia ، ثلاثة
ثلاثة ، صفر ، ما كان يمكن أن يكون
حادثًا مؤسفًا ، أثبت له
متانة الهاتف التي كنت أتحدث بها على الهاتف ،
دفعني صديق لي وسقط هاتفي
من الطابق الثاني  من
الممر في الكلية ، كنت أركض ،
كنت متوترة جدًا
، فهل سيعمل ، ألن أعود
البطارية وكان الهاتف
يعمل بشكل مدهش ، وهنا بدأ حبي
لنوكيا ، فهذه ليست مجرد آثار من
حقبة ماضية  لديه بعض
المعايير الصارمة لإضافة هاتف جديد إلى
مجموعته ، لذلك عندما أشتري هواتف خلوية ،
أضع بعض الأشياء في
الاعتبار ، أحدهما هو أنه يجب أن يكون في
حالة جيدة ،
وثانيًا يجب أن يكون في
حالة عمل كاملة لأنك تعلم أنك لا تفعل ذلك
لا تشتريها فقط لتجميعها ، فأنت
بحاجة إلى امتلاكها ، فأنت بحاجة إلى استخدامها.
لقد استثمروا الكثير من الأموال في استثمارات ميتة ،
لكنهم لا يعرفون حقًا
حقيقة أن الأمر مختلف تمامًا
بينما تم الاعتراف بمجموعة Josh على
أنها الأكبر من نوعها في
الهند ، لقد وضع عينيه على جائزة أكبر
سأذهب إليها  لحضور
موسوعة غينيس للأرقام القياسية
، أنا معروف بالفعل بكوني رجل هاتف خلوي من نوكيا
في الهند وأمسك بكتاب غينيس
للأرقام القياسية باعتباره مرموقًا
لك ولشخصيتك بالنسبة لجوش ، إنه يتعلق
بأكثر من مجرد تسجيلات أو تقدير
أعتني به  أحدق بهم كثيرًا وألقي
نظرة عليهم وأشعر بالسعادة من
الداخل
[موسيقى]